[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola maria
hola
esto que acabo de vivir yo hay chicos y
chicas que nunca lo van a vivir al
contrario están acostumbrados a que al
llegar a cualquier casa oa la escuela al
club encontrarse con gestos y miradas de
desprecio para qué viniste tú vieras
quedo en tu casa estábamos mucho mejor
sin voz eso es lo que viven muchísimos
chicos y chicas todos los días
los invito a que cierren los ojos y
piensen en alguna imagen de su propia
vida que nos haya hecho sentir sumamente
avergonzados esa vez por ejemplo en
donde mamá llegó tarde a buscarte al
colegio te tuviste que quedar sentado en
un escalón con la maestra o aquella otra
en la que un profesor te entregó un
examen aplazado diciéndote adelante de
todos otra vez usted
o hace poco cuando se te rompió una
media antes de entrar a una reunión muy
importante y no te pudiste cambiar
la tenéis la imagen la tienen
agarrarla bien fuerte
quédense la
sientan la
yo hoy acá les cuento que viene a buscar
popularidad
estoy en un momento de mi vida en el que
quiero ser famosa me quiero elevar y
para conseguirlo estoy segura de que si
nos humilló a ustedes lo puedo conseguir
entonces voy a tomar esas imágenes de
ustedes y las voy a compartir ahora
enseguida yo conseguí esas imágenes y
las voy a subir acá a esta charla
qué susto no
tus debilidades tus miedos sus
vergüenzas tus temores expuestos acá a
la vista de todos que sentís como te lo
imaginas
eso es lo que vive en cantidad de chicos
de chicas de adolescentes en las
escuelas todos los días en todo el mundo
esto cuando hablamos de acoso de
humillación entre padres en edad escolar
lo definimos como bullying el buen
consiste en hostigar humillar ignorar
agredir a un par de manera reiterada
sostenida e intencional a la vista de un
público que sostiene esas actitudes con
aplausos con miradas con gestos
descalificatorios con risas o también
callando retirándose a otro lugar
eso es el acoso escolar o el bullying y
cuando es sociedad en un espacio digital
podemos hablar de ciber bullying así que
imagínate que esas imágenes que yo
mostré recién tuyas yo se las envío a
mis amigos en los medios de comunicación
y esta misma tarde vos y tus vergüenzas
apareces en todas las redes sociales en
grupos de whatsapp del trabajo de tus
amigos de tu familia en facebook en
instagram vos y tus vergüenzas imagínate
qué sentirías al mostrarte así y desnudo
frente a la mirada de todos los demás
cuando esto se da entre niños niñas y
adolescentes hablamos de ciberacoso o
ciber bullying y ahora recordad recordar
a los chicos
conectados a tantos ni tantos tim sen en
clases virtuales que les han permitido
sin duda y les siguen permitiendo
mantener la continuidad pedagógica en
tiempos pandémicos recordad a todos los
chicos en esas pantallas con cáritas
nada más que cáritas conectándose con
otros mostrando sus vergüenzas sus
intimidades sus familias sus imprevistos
conectados con sus amigos conectados con
aquellos que no lo son y además en ese
momento cualquier chico con carita de
ángel podría estar escribiendo en el
teclado o cualquier otra cosa enviando
mensajes agraviantes a todos los mismos
que están ahí sin que el maestro
sumamente comprometido se dé cuenta
cualquier chico con carita de ángel
podría estar capturando
pantalla en ese momento y enviando esa
imagen con agravios con cuernitos con
caras con colores con insultos sí
compartiendo la con todos los chicos y
con toda la escuela y con todos los
amigos de los amigos de la escuela
eso es realmente doloroso las excusas
que podrían utilizar frente a esto si es
bueno nos estamos divirtiendo el que
hace el acoso hace eso realmente dice
bueno esto es gracioso para mí es
gracioso y yo les pregunto cuál es el
límite
cuál es el límite entre el humor y el
dolor quién marca de que uno se puede
reír o cuando uno puede sufrir
vos docente podés hacer un montón de
cosas para evitar que los chicos estén
en esta posición voz docente mamá papá
puedes hacer un montón de cosas para que
ningún chico pase por esta situación de
sufrimiento de dolor de exposición de
humillación de miedo a ir a la escuela
así que te puedo decir a ver todos los
docentes nos podemos dar cuenta cuando
esto está pasando en clase no solamente
en clase sino en clases virtuales como
porque un niño victimizado se apaga se
eleva el brillo de los ojos esquiva la
mirada se quiere ir quiere desaparecer
quiere volverse invisible y eso vos lo
podés ver
cuando un niño es victimizado cada vez
que quiere hablar en la escuela se
encuentra se encuentra con la mirada con
la risa de los compañeros el clima en el
aula cuando un niño es victimizado es
denso es pesado es agobiante y eso vos
lo ves lo que pasa es que muchas veces
no intervenimos porque te parece que te
falta tiempo o que te faltan ganas o que
la verdad tendría que aprender a reírse
un poco se fortalece te no te falta
sentido del humor porque no aprendes a
reírte de vos mismo que puedes hacer voz
docente mamá papá para prevenir detectar
e intervenir en bullying a tiempo
conecta con los chicos conecta la
indiferencia de quien está a cargo de
cuidarnos
aumenta el dolor conecta ayuda ofrece tu
mano
vos sos la luz para esos chicos que
están sufriendo de bullying enseña a
diferenciar la broma de la burla del
maltrato no es lo mismo hacer un chiste
para divertirse con los amigos que
tomara a alguien de punto y empezar a
decirles cosas que no lastiman y que vos
ves que no estás lastimando si un chico
mira a otro y ve que está por llorar que
está rojo que está violento por esa
angustia y sigue quien tiene el problema
el que está haciendo la broma enseña a
diferenciar las intenciones de quien
pone un apodo cariñoso para acercarse al
otro con cariño con amor ya que lo otro
que lo hace para este ofender no
mostrarnos
disminuirlo
avergonzarlo frente a los demás
armas redes con los docentes y con los
padres armas redes que sean sostenedoras
y que estén a disposición que sean
firmes consistentes cálidas receptivas
que no atrapen
y que no engañen simplemente que estén
ahí para poder recibir al que necesite
ayuda y hace con tus alumnos aquello que
a vos te gustaría a vos maestro te
gustaría que los docentes de tus hijos
hagan con tus hijos esos no falla nunca
convocada además a las familias sin
juicios sin prejuicios sin condena con
vocales para escucharlas y si vos sos
mamá o papá acércate a la escuela para
trabajar con el maestro mirada al
maestro como a vos te gusta que te miren
en tu trabajo
nunca minimice el dolor de un niño nunca
le ofrezcas a una mamá o un papá como
primera respuesta ante un reclamo su
hijo está fabulando
te propongo ahora que recuerdes la
escena del comienzo tu vergüenza mi
agresión la impunidad pero esta vez te
invito a que imagines que el organizador
de este evento me frena me detiene no me
deja agredir teme desconecta me apaga la
transmisión
seguramente vos te sentirías sumamente
aliviado por esa intervención esa es tu
intervención
detener frenar ofrecer una mano
pensar que todos estos actores y
cantantes tan conocidos de chicos
sufrieron bullying pero alguien los
rescató
vos podés ser esa persona que va a hacer
que el bullying deje menos huella vos
podés ser esa persona que le va a dar la
mano al que necesita salir de esa
oscuridad
de voz depende de vos docente mamá papá
vecino portera
vos podés cambiarle la vida a un niño
y recordar el límite entre la broma y el
maltrato es siempre el sufrimiento del
otro si duele no es gracioso
tal vez en lugar de apostar tanto al
sentido del humor deberíamos desarrollar
más nuestro sentido del amor muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]